tout semble ok je vais faire un test de
mon côté voir si ça fonctionne
un watch école parce que du coup je suis
là le stream il lancé sur l'ordi de kev
donc ça pourrait éventuellement aidé et
nice aussi intéressant je vois 0 message
le chat donc donc je sais
c'est paul ça marche c'est fait un truc
le prix car à kiev
façon jours
tél
e
[Musique]
ouais on dire
notre fait rien sur trop vite chez
ok ce personnage
troc est bon mois sur youtube ça marche
avait coûté salut à tous les gens sur
youtube n'est pas superman sur youtube
mais ok moi je vois que ça fonctionne
donc eu d'habitude voilà j'ai pu voir le
chat sur sur twitch mais bah du coup
rapatriés sur youtube un peu du coup
elle aujourd'hui arena où je vous disais
et donc si vous voulez jouer
vous connaissez le principe vous soyez
membre du club chaise comme france
surface comme et puis votre pierre à
l'aréna donc comme tous les après-midis
maintenant c'est donc c'est depuis quand
vous annoncez twitter youtube
aujourd'hui en fait sur les deux
d'habitude moi je me suis je surveille
plus cher twitch mais son maintient
petit un petit bug aujourd'hui et donc
on va plutôt être ici enfin on sera un
peu partout on a donc vérifié de
sentences savent bien sûr twitch les
bourses tanguent humble car c'est sans
ses marchés
or pour l'instant dans la rénove pas de
nombreux autres inscrits donc bouger
vous parce que sa course dans un quart
d'heure et on n'est que trois joueurs
donc perd peut-être un peu trop
d'intérêts aujourd'hui je vais jouer
dans cet aréna puis l'auto je suis
jamais parti mais que vous sera de se
marrer donc ses 960 aujourd'hui donc
c'est une version que j'aime bien et
puis mon frère explique un peu ce qu'on
fait et cetera et cetera quoi voilà moi
sinon vous je suis pas con ça va alors
un nouvel inscrit enfin monter petit à
petit les coûts qui suit un master class
ya beaucoup de ces gentils dans l'infra
d'autres h course leur jette pas une par
semaine ou peut-être on verra le reste
qu'on peut suivre mais on essaiera d'en
faire plus ou moins deux par mois
minimum
merci aussi à pierre chaze el kid ils
remercient pour que la vidéo c'est sympa
et on essaye d'en faire le plus loin
possible
c'est quand la reina king je crois que
ça va commencer début mai à l'aréna qui
nie donc d'ici deux petites semaines un
petit peu moins peut-être même sur
twitch s'est toujours pas parti il ya
des chances qu'on fasse ou le flux du
beau aujourd'hui je fais juste un petit
à petit c'est un bug qui a aucun rapport
avec nous donc il est très probable que
ça passe ça peut partir à tout moment
comme ne jamais partir mais ce n'est pas
dépendant de notre volonté bonjour les à
l'aréna king comme tu étais en train de
répondre en fait il y en aura une mais
ce sera tout un côté on va mettre tous y
aura tous hurlé title tuesday beaucoup
mieux que les arénas un beaucoup plus
intéressant donc voilà je te laisse mais
le bug sur foot malheureusement ça se
règlera soit tout seul soit pas du tout
on peut rien faire n'est ce pas et
toutes les chaînes peut-être pas
collaborer c'est vrai tous leurs crimes
points est hors du coup un bon courage à
toi dur allez merci
salut qu'à chaque ni bruno astuces qui
noie sa décoration switch donc du coup
être dans les caves et ouais il ya un
souci et je sais pas assez indépendant
on tourne
fonds n'ont pour l'instant des six
joueurs seulement dans l'arena
[Musique]
n'hésitez pas à venir après je sais que
malheureusement il ya plein de gens qui
doit vouloir voir le live sur twitter
parce qu'ils en ont l'habitude et
doivent se dire ah y'a pas de live
aujourd'hui
mais si c'est quand il est avec le
tuesday du coup devant john and food
rend alors là j'imagine que c'est dans
le nom title tune des stocks les marges
après pour attaquer si l'on changé le
concept mais non non non
est ce que c'est aujourd'hui qu'on va le
troisième volet de l'anonyme zoo demande
bruno web elle fait elle est sortie
c'est la partie et de ec2 les ressources
défensive tchèque et détournement de la
vidéo mais elle est sortie ce matin
e
lucas et éventuellement sur youtube est
ce que c'est vrai nom des gens
contrairement à twitch bas je pense
qu'il ya des gens que de remettre leur
vrai nom s'est connecté leur compte
youtube avec leur adresse gmail y en a
d'autres qui mettent juste des pseudo
par exemple il ya eu 8 passes dans ses
critiques riquel dans membres ont pas
que son vrai nom quoi comme comme ricou
44 mais après il ya d'autres
il ya d'autres alors pour l'aréna écoute
vayssié ça est ce que quelqu'un d'un peu
mettre dans le live dans le chatt
youtube le lien pour l'aréna si j'ai le
bon lien c'est la kova rennes à 960 donc
[Musique]
chaque jour en écho comme l'écho arena
dont fo taille dans la zone jeu tu fais
tournois etc et donc faut être membre du
club
quescom france si vous avez des liens
tout ça je vous ensuite à tête les nets
dans le chat pour que les gens qui ne
connaissent pas puisse appuyer dessus
tous
ken bruno
ap ok je te pète ça soufflera pas en
fait du coup c'est quoi ta réponse et
frank bruno où ni l'un ni l'autre
d'ailleurs peut-être
merrick ou 44 ouais donc ces quatre cent
quarante quatre sorties du week-end mais
je pensais que tmg pas remarqué qu'elle
inquiète de plus je reconnais ce pseudo
bon du coup on joue donc même temps dans
une dizaine de minutes
donc ça laisse encore un peu le temps de
venir donc comme je vous disais non
joués échec en direct nous allons
tournoi autres collègues covan à 960
c'est une arène et qui a duré une heure
et demie aujourd'hui on va jouer aux
échecs 960 donc suivre et un peu mes
parties et voilà
simon qui disent c'est pas la bonne
visiblement la bonne qu a du coup bon je
vois que tu witch est toujours en pls
dommage
bon il ya des chaînes qui m'a
or dit ce qu'ils ont construit mais des
blessés des bulles est un [ __ ]
marchessault
je n'aime pas sûr c'est dire avec
cela fonctionne et ok c'est comme ça
hein
1 donc je sais pas dans le choc ça parce
que cette bonne à rien pas quelques
conseils pour 960 avant de commencer de
montag alors les conseils vous éviter
bien ça marche toujours nord 960 va
écouter essayer de faire comme aux
échecs de contrôler le centre de
développer un d'essayer d'avoir un plan
de jeu un tout cohérent
voilà mais en gros c'est comme aux
échecs c'est important tous les
principes qui sont voir des chèques
devront se retrouver aussi dans ce sens
60 donc bien se développer bien contre
le sens caché ton roi etc
emmanuel qui est d'abord sur tweets
choix non mais en fait c'est chaque jour
ce sera sur twitter juste aujourd'hui on
sait pas il ya un bug et twitch alors ça
pourrait débloquer tout seul et se
penser autant dans cinq secondes au
temps dans une heure autant pas avant
demain je ne sais pas dur à dire alain
tout cas pour l'instant c'est comme ça
et dans quoi ils 960
la difficulté c'est qu'il ya un peu les
pièces tirées au sort au début donc on a
moins de repères tout ça mais après si
tu pense juste à bien développer les
pièces cachées ton roi prendre le centre
mais non ça va aller et après petit à
petit ça tombera dans des positions à
peu près normal et donc appréciés de 2,2
retourne sur ses pattes etc
ou encore
minutes pour s'inscrire
comme dit manuel s'il me bat
qu'il respecte et conseils en 960
j'essaie de me les appliquer à moi même
aussi les conseils 7 h f il dit qu il
jamais arrivé à aucun 960 comment vas tu
veux comme aux échecs en fait hier que
dans une position classique aux échecs
ton roi blanc devant g1 ou en c1 et à
thouars à côté pour 960 c'est pareil le
roi hier à angers 1
la tour en f1 ou s'il fait grand croix
c'est un tour d un peu importe d'où il
part au début et après comme aux échecs
classique faut pas que tu passes par une
caste contrôlée par l'adversaire faux
pacte est déjà budgétée à tour était
déjà objet tournant alors belge à
l'appui demande le lien on va s il
pouvait le mettre dans le tchat ce
serait super peut-être emmanuel jeu tu
connais le lien c'est moi j'ai un lien
mais c'est un cépage et ça laisse pas le
bon lien il vous en bien
oui sinon je vous explique la marche à
suivre
c'est simplement tu vois sur check point
comme il faut qu'ils soient membres du
club ché scom france message gaulliste a
déjà joué des arénas les autres joueurs
battus est déjà parce que c'est une
condition indispensable
tu vas d'anjou et échecs en direct un
bataillon de jouer ou tournois en
tournois et tu trouves direct ce premier
tournoi là je vois moi kova rennais à
960 avec le petit pion chez ce point
comme le petit drapeau france voilà et
puis tu cliques qui fait rejoindre et
puis voilà après ces énoncés
sipa
dubost pas la case déplacement rock
ouais faut que tu as même ton roi à la
main qui te prends-tu l'amène jusqu'à g1
tu lâches dans leurs marchés
bah presse a toujours rêvé de faire des
boks clip ou quoi ça c'est inhérent jeux
sur internet
mais normalement sinon ça marche sans
trop de soucis quoi
faut pas toucher
roy mais ça c'est comme aux échecs
classiques sont rois déjà bougé
toutefois tu auras plus grandes rock et
si tu as déjà touchette et tour sur le
côté jeu pourra plus faire le rock
bon ça te suis content d'aider peut-être
celle publiée mais sinon c'est pas censé
possible bon pour l'instant n'est pas
méga nombreux on est 18
allez moi c'est de monter un peu sous
ses beaux sites est possible mais
peut-être qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup
d'entre vous qui sont membres du club
ché ce club je sais qu'au début c'était
plutôt une cover n1 bitstream et est du
coup si vous étiez demande du club
d'istres il faut il avoir la phobie être
membre du club
pièce comme france donc chercher le club
rejoignait le club
il n'y a pas besoin d'approuver mans par
un modérateur ou quoi ça sera immédiat
et donc vous permettra de jouer ce
tournoi sinon vous pourrait juste ne pas
le jouer vous ne verrez pas en fait pour
être membre du club et
et benji love qui a bien trouvé
finalement ok c'est cool ça valait moins
de cinq minutes donc tenez vous prêts
que moi le membre du club de colo est un
petit truc recherche en bas à gauche à
la place j'irais dessus tu vas l'on
recherche
tu remplis banques leurs ges comme
espace france je suis entré hommes
et puis après il va te proposer des
clubs tu fais club battu fait une petite
recherche un peu comme tu peux essayer
de trouver le truc je vous retrouver le
club de temps est ce que je peux voir un
lien pour t'envoyer dessus si vous
l'avez fait le avant moi j' en train de
chercher moi de mon côté club voilà tu
peux donc club tac
voilà je vais t'envoyer un lien tempo
sur le tchat
voilà ici on vous l'avez dans le chatt
youtube
vous pouvez y aller saluer eric qui
vient d'arriver
donc ça c'est le lien pour rejoindre le
club chaise comme france diva dessus tu
cliques et puis voilà
tu rejoins après tu vois dans la zone de
jeu et tu peux t'inscrire sur la rien le
lierre qui défile une trentaine de
joueurs mais vu qu'on sait que ça pose à
13 heures 15 avril à la minute où il va
maintenant sous connaissez le principe
s'inquiètent pas trop trop en avance
est-ce que la position ceux des pièces
change à chaque partie je pense que oui
cet échec après je ne sais pas j'ai
jamais joué de d'arena en en 960 dont je
sais pas exactement c'est quand même le
principe
enfin
voilà c'est qu'on joue plusieurs
positions différentes donc je pense ce
sera tiré au sort à chaque fois salut à
leur enième rêvait excuses de questeur
kiyonari des saluts et vous les gars
n'hésitez pas à venir jouer l'aréna dès
que des vous pouvez 25 joueurs ben
écoute on arrive à la petite trentaine
petit à petit
alors hier que ceux qui
là pendant le master class
s'il dit je ne vois pas un seul bien sur
youtube je ne sais pas rien j'en vois un
truc j'ai écrit quand même la tanière
je fais copier coller et puis ça va
marcher seul ryan med
il y obtient in bayer chez lui la can il
respecte le confinement tranquille mais
kevin hill fait pas mal de stream
bah je crois qu'il en a fait un par jour
chaque jour depuis un mois donc ce soit
ici sur bitstream les deux etc
et c est là l événement un petit repos
donc aujourd'hui c'est moi qui fais être
votre autre au trading
nicolau non plus parce qu'on va en fait
un pas peut-être ce que j'écris ça
paraît pas écrit n'importe quoi j'ai
juste fait des lettres vous allez me
dire si vous voulez un truc j'ai connu
le lien dans le tchat bon sinon on fait
si chaud arrive à trouver sur che ce que
je peux le faire où j'ai refusé d'en
club de chercher le club ou pire vous
êtes mais si quelqu'un peut copier le
lien six mois par an ça marche pas je ne
sais pas alors son problème c'est que
l'aréna qu'on vend 12 minutes et déjà 31
joueurs donc bon m trouvable
ma part
je vois que c'est toujours pas c'est
toujours pas lancer ou si je sais pas
vous me direz si sûr twitch s'élancer ou
pas en tout cas je crois pas je crois
que je vote pour la chaîne déconnecté de
mon côté donc c'est pas de chance après
pendant que je vais jouer j'aurai du mal
à checker le chat ou un temps de faire
des petites aller-retour diaby fait qui
dit encore world team cup m'écoute merci
moi c'est une super idée bien content
d'arthuis participé il ya six mois ok
c'est parti bart van hove et la position
un peu étrange
il fait 4 il prend le sens logique
gfr b5 comme ça je la taxe champions
avec mon fond à 8,6 me permettent de
faire je m'en fous à éviter un peu bougé
madame ok il défend son pion comme ça du
coup son foin qui aime bien faire mais
je vais faire c'est cinq bons prend un
peu le centre ça ressemble à une sorte
de sicilienne et puis j'ai ici il faudra
sortir mon second fou
bon à prendre
comment ça se passe c'est dur de
vraiment savoir au début
[Musique]
comment ça va se passer c'est parti on
prend le centre à fond donc je m'enferme
un peu m'en fous je fais un trou en d5
mais j'espère pouvoir colmater les cases
avec mes cavaliers mettre un camion de
6,5 à lyon le 7 ou en b 6 et puis
peut-être rauque et puis après on
revient donc à prévoir un conseil si je
le voudrais c'est peut-être ne pas
manquer trop trop vite parfois sans
donner votre adresse
bon presque ça c'est clair que vous avez
un endroit facile où il y avait beaucoup
je viens pour sa belle dame
rassemblement je viens de partir plus
tôt rockets de ce côté que l'autre
donc voilà là au moins ça fait réfléchir
mon adversaire me fais b4 ok il veut
venir au combat il veut voir son fou là
bas je vais fermer
donc ça ça ne permet pas d'ouvrir son
fou son mauvais coup j'avais envie de
dire son fric est blanche de kasma
repeindre il fait des quatre maintenant
ok alors on peut changer en d4
on peut peut-être faire juste des six ce
qui me dérobe train est ce que c'est si
grave
on peut prendre un passant aussi mais
j'ai pas moins sympa de prendre en
passant je vais juste sortir les pièces
encore un peu plus
ok il
ferme en ferme la position donc mon
cavalier fuite et peu au top je vais
faire des six que nous avons calqué
pouvoir sortir sur 17 donc position très
fermé mais à mon x 8 aussi pas au top
maintenant qui m'a bien bloqué le centre
mais on verra si je peux arriver à jaked
5 peut-être un moment ça va pas être si
simple à réaliser mon cas et beast il se
penche vers lemaitre verra quatre pour
aller un peu regardé le pion c3 faire
des choses par là bas c'est de faire à
saint caprais est passé à les labos qui
l'a fait petit homme en cavale il avait
comme j'avais annoncé donc ça me tient
une petite pression sur lille d'am-dam
ces deux menaces peut-être qu'elle y
prend ses quatre donc s'en va l'éviter
en un qui coûte dams et 7
et peut-être que je peux avoir l'idée de
jouer grand casting on va voir comment
ça peut se passer f4 pas mal joué je
vais le laisser changer ce qu'il veut il
aura le deuxième qui avait l'équivalent
des cas être bon et impartiaux devant
rock well as et hop
et or
pas mal jury prend l'espace je vais
sortir sous et s'il me recycler
peut-être vers g5 ouvrir avec g prend
effet un joueur on verra mais avant
position position peu claires un projet
d'un v6 comme ressource pour klose qui
avait un lien étroit éventuellement on
verra comment ça se passe
la cadence j'ai toujours pas regarder
s'il est dur à jouer ou pas en tout cas
fait jouer un peu vite assez du blitz
allez on attaque ce cavalier on ramène
le fou de ce côté
nous
pour le 3g forcer l'adversaire à perdre
du temps elle défend j'ai sûrement
ramener la demande b6 le cas et 17 ans
m6 ce drame est un peu les pièces en jeu
mais je trouve qu'ils ont une pression
pas mal à part le foie est vite qui fait
vraiment rien mais bon il ya aussi une
fois celle fois un qui font pas grand
chose
allez h5 on va pas perdre trop de temps
sur ce coup on chasse le cavalier
les verts rêvent 2 1 ok on va ramener un
cavalier faire pression sur le centre
peut-être falloir des sacrifices qui se
dessine à base de l'éprouver cinq es14
choses comme ça donc ils m'attaquent je
recule et maintenant je vais peut-être
faire g5 ou gpra f5 ouvrir ouvrir ouvrir
à fond contre contre son roi dernier
madame juste au cas où
je pense qu'elle est une très bonne case
ici pour entrer verrou 3 fouet f3
d'accord et du coup la dame
une questions au fou il défend avec le
roi allez on va prendre un f5 ont souv
la colonne g pour la tour ce que je veux
jouer en plein de copains de temps en
temps je ferais bien je ferai bien le 4
on va peut-être juste rené lecavalier
ici
alors
e
faut prendre un coup franc d'alves 4
veut échanger les dames c'est un peuple
autres tout ça j'ai envie de dire
si tu veux mais je vais attaquer des 5e
passage
les pions des cinq risquent d'être
difficiles à défendre me semble ok donc
le pion des cinq difficile à défendre
je vais le prendre avec le foot local
avec lecavalier le fou ce thème est
aussi doté d'une qualité mais au moins
on garde le clouage à l'oeuf ou trois je
vais enlever comme ça je mens cavaliers
reprend des sacrifices apprend qu'elle 6
min combinaison que je fais ça
kg
un écouteur
je vais aujourd'hui les pions je rends
la qualité s'ils veulent apprendre
ok il prend pas c'est pas mal tenté il
va essayer de faire un blocage
mais chassez ce cavalier et puis que les
pions se mettent à lancer je m'ouvre la
colonne pour entrer comme à tort et
bajaur ont d'ailleurs et je gagne le fou
ok mon victoire en sept parties mais
bonne des cancers m2 le barbarian donc
mais le parti on verra un nouvel
adversaire
marquant maury qui montrent le lien du
tournoi ouais vous puissiez le donne et
si vous pouvez sur le
sur le live donc je répète il faut être
membre du club
jess comme france et il faut il faut
faire quoi d'autre et puis après pour
jean nous tombons la zone de jeu et
c'est alors un nouvelle position et on
adversaire a joué des 4 je vais le
copier je fais des cinq donc comme d'hab
vous avez partie avant j'essayais de me
développer et c'est faux que les pièces
arrivent à jouer pas essayer de laisser
trop pièces hors jeu ou de choses comme
ça
là il ya un point faible dans la
position de part et d'autre c'est
l'option h7 ou h2 qui est défendu par
personne et donc vous bien avoir à
l'oeil et pas l'élection prise alors
food et de bon pourquoi pas mais je
trouve ça développe pas grand chose mais
ce qu'il a nié
il y fait un
e suis pas bête du tout je peux faire
c'est cinq super un petit temps
peut-être pas si mal essayé de lutter
pour le centre donc si proche frais
d'altran et puis il faut objets dans le
rouge orange espère avoir le centre un
peu comme dans les gants midam faire
l'option ses seins il faut changer son
fonds central d et avoir 5 ans 8 qui
partira mais donc c'est pas mal ce
qu'ils gagnent et mbo soirée dame je
recule mais le coup d'après j'aimerais
bien faire c'est simple
centre voilà c'est le projet qui est b6
il peut sauter en c4 parce qu'ils aient
une bonne case pour lui
puis bon quand même faut penser au
développement google 5 j'aime bien ça
prend le centre je pourrais mon kayak 8
l'armée angers 6 sûrement c'est sa
meilleure case et puis on verra la suite
ce que j'aime bien c'est de son cahier
en g3 parce qu'on ne peut pas trop aller
à quatre une fille l'impulsion de près
je le prendre à moi pas de contre
indications
donc ça c'est manger j'aurais pu prendre
un cavalier aussi mais on prend avec le
ch ou pourquoi pas ça me sort une pièce
il fait petit rock maintenant très bien
et je sors ce qu'avait bien ça je
pourrais moi aussi peut-être faire petit
rock et puis j'oublie pas surtout mon
idée de faire au 5 de prendre le centre
donc ça leur quand même savoir pas votre
composition comme pour les noirs
maintenant on en tourne plus on va bien
contrôlé le centre donc plutôt au diable
ou trois ok logique iv sortira son
d'autres fous on prend deux centres
tous ces trois bons noms
ça attaque pas le cul en fat ont donc
juste sa place le flou enjeux auxquels
nous vante aussi
flash 5 peut-être le prendre mais ce pas
madame qui les fonctions centrales
c'est un petit coup de tours s'est vite
remettre la tour sur une colonne ouverte
et on garde le pion ces deux en toile de
chanvre indien
en point de mire
d'amd de hockey pas mal joué bons fous
des huit qui fait pas grand chose je
vais me bouger comme ça hop ça me
permettre d'utiliser l'école centrale
pour du tour peut-être joué quatre des
cinq ensuite pendant qu'ils accueillent
ces quatre je viens pour attaquer là
alors il prend ici je reprends pas mal
ce pion des six qui prend les cases du
cahier j32 vers ce f4
ok tant que le jeu pourquoi quoi l on va
quand même pas repayer c-46 dames 35 g
km 3 du coup la dame notes voir je sais
pas aller ailleurs et au moins manquer
et b6 est revenu en jeu bien placés ici
force l'adversaire a trouvé un coup
donc
je fais la fourchette dont j'avais parlé
donc j'attaque la dame j'attaque la tour
eiffel j'attaque accessoirement le pion
ces deux donc ça doit gagner du matériel
dames
dans 24 d'accord vous fait tort si pour
le 5e jeu prendront jetteront
intermédiaire j'organise tempo sur les
dames il prend 1,4 c'est prend quand
même ce cavalier ici
je prends la jeune ici des échanges
parce que parce que pas trop dérangeant
tous ces échanges en étant donné qu'on a
pas mal de matériel davance tran plus
mon rôle sera bien je pourrais le g7 je
pourrais jouer sur la colonne h avec une
tour par exemple ou quelque chose comme
ça donc ça c'est plutôt sympa et je me
ramène pas assez de médecins à dams et
de enfin petit échec chez ses maîtres le
roi soit colonna et roger cep s'il vient
enfin je crois quand même plus ce genre
de coups pour ramener les tours et
essayer d'aller mater à salusse soba
l'année qui écrit dans le chat de twitch
fronsac alors c'est déjà parti alors je
compte triche est à leur position de
départ
ok vous pousse un pion conseillé de
prendre le centre il ya hélas là et qui
essaye de faire venir les gens donc que
c'est bien de dire ça dont je prends une
grosse partie donc et pourquoi pas moi
je vais jouer les pions sans trop gavé
g6
mais aussi
comme saddam pourra jouer parce qu'au
jeu alors que la menace est bloqué
là-bas mais on verra comment ça se
goupille je vais prendre l'espace
ok bon j'arrête le
allier avec la dame j'ai un bon il peut
prendre
au nom de notre cavalier mais j'ai envie
de vite activer les pièces d'être en jeu
très vite dans le quartier et j'en
souffre c'est pas idiot de hockey donc
madame je vais la garder
on va dire ici centralisée
car c'était notre option bien sûr
intéressant mais comme ça on se place ok
ça je voulais plutôt prendre en passant
a obligé pendant pas son jeu possible en
aller et on s'envoie dont certains ont
120 là le foot blanchir à verser 2 il va
me chasser mon fou à cash 4 je crois
qu'on peut le laisser faire on va le
laisser faire
dommage c'est top
évitez pitt blague à base de découverte
mais ils font face
demain
où va-t-il on va garder tout son respect
renâclent à tour
s'il ment
ok
ces trois sets permettre de jouer les
grands axes
tdf qui à travers les menaces
éventuellement qui est rangé leurs
maillots le seront prises il attaque le
pion et de hockey on va te faire ça
ok ok
on peut jouer la finale
finale club est si mal à les rendre
accessibles si le final on rentrera dans
le final je pense que son tirage qui est
peut être un peu faible
je trouve que je
peu lui développé alors 5 ça défend h4
je peux prendre en passant
ou faire un coup comme cavalier f5 qui
est 5 j'aime bien théo 5 kf5 avait fait
refouler cette gamme c'est ça son idée
si je prends les six iep vous pouvez 20
clouage bon si je fais la gorge et rang
[Musique]
franck ce truc
100 g par semaine les arches pas
convaincu ma décision
pas super qu'on récupère stage fait
mourir vous faisiez site échec ok ça on
s'en doute
on va bouger landrin
je fasse gaffe au foie
quinze jours
prise comprend six cavaliers
on va le prendre si ce jeu peut prendre
six comme ça batta qui ça ici
c'est à pied ont fait un clonage là
c'était pas mal c'est pas mal on peut
prenez le cas d' aller je me suis un
autre clou âge
torres
m'en fous un petit coup de cavale est
ici
bon jeu
la position mais on n'est pas en train
de faire une grande différence pour
l'instant mais on attaque un peu les
faiblesses par ci par là
en fait si simple de tout défendre et un
clouage bon problème c'est que j'ai pas
vu quelquefois 5 quand même s'en sortir
plus ou moins par une qualité dans
l'histoire
mais bon des 600 l'er-6 envers 5 juin
qui était de moins c'est dommage parce
que c'était quand même une superposition
rondelle on ne peut saloper en prenant
la tactique mais au final tu aimes pas
mal d'options
donc quand même une chance de pouvoir
gagner faire faire de gaffe
trois trains pour la qualité mais
heureusement pas de qui ont passé mais
peut-être qu'on verrait à leur tour et
chaque classe est ce qu'elle est ici
on essaie de prendre les cases de la
toro qui m'attaquent le pion on va les
défendre
bon déjà qui est des cinq c'est pas
terrible je parle de petites erreurs
pas mal de petites erreurs qui peuvent
coûter cher faire un chèque
on voit ici ok
comment on peut le rendre
bon
on as une fourchette au passage
l'élite
façon
cavalli
qui la sort juste cavaliers je vais
continuer à monter membres il assure je
pourquoi parce que je lui fous qui le
domine pour l'instant
donc on va voir je vais essayer de faire
que trois rois c-53 b6 une fois que je
serai là bas ça peut être intéressant
parce que ok j'attaque message
une crainte qui ont passé alors on a
varié il m'attaque le fou je centralise
et j'essayais de tous défendant le mieux
possible
et g37 qu'il il s'active à eernegem l'on
a là bas on a testé cette peut-être
l'entité chèque
ça pas grand chose certes pas grand
chose je vais faire c'est 5
éventuellement forcément le coup de la
neige
allez me dire c5 c6 à l'étranger pour
ses succès 6
moi pour l'instant story 4 je voulais
faire cavalier
qu'ils étaient cinq pôles car si
facilement
je vais d'ailleurs ce qu'a laissé leur
sortir ce calme on peut
f tient compte et on fait un petit échec
ici au kef et
ça c'est mal joué
pas bien jusqu'où
pas bien joué parce qu'il a ce petit
psion qui file du coup comme ça parce
que leur échec de nouvelles une pression
trop vêtements foutu on va essayer de
l'embêter si on peut sa patte ça
m'embêtait grand chose ici mais bon
on verra
non c'est comme un fou
parce que c'est peut-être mieux
d'abandonner d'ailleurs dans une
perspective du tournoi n'a rien j'en
sais rien
ce sont
tous les pions j'aime bien ma télé
j'abandonne donc bonne partie bravo
triche est et c'est une partie longue
ses comptes fin de partie on y perdre
c'est la vie en dommage un jour ça va
être assez gagnant mais mais que sa
tournée un moment à cause de ce x 5
échecs où j'ai laissé la torah jeu suit
en mer après c'était quand même trend
position j'aurais pas dû me prendre f4
comme socle
prenons la suggestion qui est toujours
en pleine page dans le tournoi bah je
vais toujours noir et tu vas dans com
arena en fait tout va reina ça va
marcher
alors je cherche un match vivant des
passants c'est très long ouais c'est
c'est parti alors qu'on a les blancs ok
donc j'en souffre c'est bien de pousser
ses quatre en attaque h7 donc fait jouer
notre premier fou et je vais faire
faire ensuite b4 comme ça j'ai mis deux
jeux qui vous auquel 6
quatre essais de faire f 5 ans dans
l'espace je sais pas quel point c'est
bien joué ça parce que ça fait beaucoup
de coups de pions se développer on va
tenter
on va voir alors elle joue aussi ce sur
un cavalier dont j'ai déception b4 en
l'air bon je vois plus rien déjà les
gars très mauvais début de partie
prince était pas la fin du monde sait qu
un pion
on verra un bon j'ai de la chance il a
pas pris il ya une prendre ce pion bon
c'est des idées de kayes h3 savoir
qu'ils ont un cahier qui défendent l
option f4 donc on prend un peu de
l'espace avel dame ça de ce point de vue
là c'est pas trop mal allez je vais
faire peut-être juste
j'ai 3
le temps de trois des cinq ok pas mal
e
[Musique]
est ce qu'on défend je serai
sans être échangé pas évident comme
choix
le temps
allez je vais m'essayer changer s'il
veut tu vois pas de trop malin comme
décision pour l'honneur de prendre en
main
je vais prendre le centre finalement
dans qu'on défende
pion aux 4
pour l'instant ça va à peu près on va
essayer de faire un 5 montre comme ça
là
amos est ok galop 7 2 7 6 11 9
bon
se passe je continue
alors
normal on va récupérer les pions défend
toujours f4 au passage on a un très bon
coup caisse blanche il a fait 2-1 aussi
faire petit rack pour ne servent pas à
grand chose
allez va faire tir a aussi déjà fait
retirer tout ce qu'elle a avec mon jeu
c'est pareil vinnitsa missclick à fond
bon sortir de verture gba position j'ai
les yeux braqués vers son roi c'est
quand même c'est quand même sympa je
vais faire un petit coucou sert à rien
comme ça évite l'écueil b4
et puis il sera temps ensuite de penser
comment attaquer
donc avec la batterie sur la grande et
vénale peut-être f5 un moment mais
pourtant j'aime bien moins de 4 5 6 qui
bloque son fou 4 mètres une perf de
blain dg de la chaire kg 5 15 jours et
laisse un peu trop vite ça va parler des
24 d'être une idée ok c'est cette donc
je porte mon idiot j'avais déception
c'est dans l'air enfilage des trucs à
chaque coup se joue pas très bien je
joue pas très bien alors c'est à dire
dans un autre
et prend les cinq mêmes sages épaules
j'espère ça on va défendre le pion à
trois qui a aidé 4 je penche pour la
tour c'est que ça continue et par h 4 h
5 si je peux plus vite possible
donc ils m'attaquent g2 on va défendre
le bouquet les quatre derniers jours
c'est bien joué de sa part
je vais quand même juste bouger la dame
on ressent la leçon
après tout mais une fois de plus avec ma
connerie de faire une petite gaffe et
ben d'une position qui a l'air hyper
sympa ça devient le moyen moyen -
l'épreuve 7 que ça donne
qu'il prenne cette visite base le vent
ce que je dois le faire sinon je peux
revenir en quatre sets dame prend d'un
projet si ce moment on regarde le pion -
c'est passionnant mais bon
on prendra notre ange est ici sont des
changes
nous c'est de gagner la finale bon il
parle là c'est un bon client des 4 et
faire travailler mais bon d'après mme
sept joueurs étrangers 6 bon ok taux
refi je vais mettre un cavalier là bas
blain un peu tout sauvegarder des cinq
en vue et qui est l'effet calais 5
pourquoi pas bonnes cases pour le
cavalier je ne chasse et de l'ain non
bah ma foi qui revient si j'avais pensé
que free cash 4 plutôt bien ici c'est
pas mon jeu parce qu'ils font est
complètement idiot
il est très mal absolu
elle l'a ramené en g3 jeu le ramener en
le 4g pas mener à bien me placer
centrale il faut faire v5 et des trucs
là bas quand on vers un prêt
saison des six sur l'actu
déjà ça c'est une bonne case ce jeu ok
bon kf3 qui va me tomber dessus
ce que ceci 1
est ce que c'est si rare j'aurais dû
prendre avant des quatre bons et
supérieurs des clés de match bah écoutez
j'ai d'échapper à m'attendre
on va pas se plaindre ok bon petit
miracle d'être encore en vie
un constat pousser les pions ont tous
lequel tu es on va monter le roi ok nous
allons aller bien plus loin on va faire
ça
c'est bloqué ce qu'on peut bloquer tac
nous allons essayer d'aller à dame
bon ok miracle a déjà fait un matin
quand même la triche est de retour la
paire des comptes triche est tout à
l'heure et de prendre la revanche on qui
recommence avec son g4 qui est pas bête
qui peut être du tout qu'est-ce qu'on va
être en face enfin la même chose à part
une chose rejouer d'être 5
mon fou de cases noires ça peut être un
génie mais bon puisque les journées à
toi une fois donne prend
[Musique]
et jugé six
ils menacent match jambes et j'en ai
déjà pas laisser décharger son fouille
d'un actif là bas qui m'a m'embête
que
si hockey mais se place bon moi j'ai
créé une batterie
gniark là c'est pas mal
par quel point ce pas mauvais mais bon
le clip s'en prend aux tories s'y
attaquent un pion charteau réfute
bêtement pour défendre c'est pas rien de
si génial mais ma foi
or je restais bientôt j'en aime bien
alors il veut pousser
vas-y tu pousses un spy au tri fin
bien voulu pouvoir être le tir ac mais
je peux pas donc
donc les gens les perdants
prochainement à tout ça
on se ressemble
chose on a le rôle
bree
donc voila tu vas me faire ça plus tard
je pense que tu es on va juste le faire
c'est de voir la position
profitez de la torah 2 qui fait
n'importe quoi là bas pour ouvrir le
centre est allé frapper si possible
alors ça suffit c'est pas faire de gaffe
comme ça fait deux parties de suite si
on file à rien c'est déjà quelque chose
ok c'est un trajet qui on va chasser
cette dame
ok pas mal joué
juste mettre les tours au centre bon on
fait ce qu'on disait on se prend pas
trop la tête et puis on vers un bouquet
de ferrage 5
j'ai quatre peut-être dans ces 4 sinon
leicester en prend son cavalier dans le
détruire la structure centrale
donc ça c'est pas trop mal on est bien
là c'est logique
un petit coup là bas
ok c'est adam place et l'âme
donc on
bien blindé qu'est-ce qu'on fait un plat
sur ses pattes du dam c4
tron coup fait en face de la tour eiffe
ans
parent
c'est mon idéal idéal jeune bien
quelques dessins que c'est bien joué de
sa part logique bien placé de cavalli
six centrales
[Musique]
bon sang gens peuvent tourner
peut être une idée
au printemps je sais pas c'est juste
faire des coups pas si mal de manière
générale tour il veut te faire du roi de
l'instant ça va marcher
[Musique]
j'envoie les pièces
soro alphonse de ces deux alors tournons
maintenant j'avais dit que je
l'empêchais en fait je ne l'empêchent
plus donc évidemment c'est un peu con
con mais juste bouger la dame
s'il veut changer
je
ok les changes
qu'ils gardent un oeil là bas sur l'air
du temps d'un set
il prend du fou ok
bon quand même être une tour en lui
respectent rarement pris à cadres bon
qu'elle élève 3 il veut faire qui est
bicis
30 30
son chemin
td s'ils lisent les prend
cavalier je préfère des vitraux madame
je pense à dame gomes sato qui ça j'ai
vu je prends et je prends à 4 finalement
c'est fini ok bon c'est mieux passé
celle là j'ai pas lâcher de pions pièce
ou deux tours en 1 forcément ça aide
bon
ou encore les droits quand j'en fus
hockey
ben ouais je vois 6-2 vite je suis aussi
de jolis on va activer ce fou dans le
coin on va tirer son collègue fou
déjà des mici coquet aux cavaliers
leucate
ok le 4 4 4 si tu eu envie de faire mais
bon au lieu de fermer
cette fois chien là bas tout seul et
aussi je prends les caisses du cavalier
f1 ça paye les mountain stratégie
d'enfermement des pièces adverse
il n'y a pas de pions des cas pour
l'instant qui fait des trois à lui tenir
là il se centralise
bon et j'en après la paire de fou c'est
pas rien c'est déjà quelque chose
je vais pas y toucher je vais continuer
à me développer
comment on va faire
ok je sais pas comment faire autrement
ça s'appelle à mal cette rupture au
centre
donc
livrés à 7 juin s'il a besoin elle sera
pas mal le cavalier en 2006 on a des
bonnes cases pour les pièces ça c'est
cool
après il faut pas craquer car ça va se
cacher avec le fou on va pas se faire
harceler plus
or tout qu'est allé sans le cavalier
4 veut pas laisser entendre le centre
je voudrais qu elle aussi ses défauts et
3,6 kg est intéressant ça reste
intéressant pour la suite
problème tous les deux
ok maintenant mettre un petit coup de
fulham a quand même si elle donnait une
qualité je la prendrai et s'ils donnent
pas de qualités il est complètement
bloqué squillaci communes ont fait un
petit coup de ses six ça va empêcher du
cahier des 5
donc on garde ses pièces en pls tout
faux effet un sa bouche quoi allez on va
conseiller l'attaquent
détroit
petit bout de cavaliers si on attaquait
f3 en blouson plonge
au rabais les deux il se déclenche mais
on va encaisser du matériel pour château
passage
une des deux tours ce qui est assez cool
au ps on replace la dame est bien sur
cette diagonale
match 4 je pencherais juste aux recettes
et c'est pas très grave
daniel 6 ça commence liste des
embrouilles
ça commence les embrouilles
bon allez craquer de venir ici
on est pas mal d'efforts
relisez donc le cavaliere menace b400 de
melfi tonfa tours 8
et à partir lancé cette avec le roi donc
au final ça va
son final
et qu'est ce qui va nous jouer fois je
crois
bon on va écouter on y va quand même
on
pour le matin l'échec
enfin on va faire
enfin à faire ça
mais là ce matin
ok
m
partir en 16,7 être le roi ok on est
caché et maintenant on leur en a trois à
l'air de bien sûr mater comme il faut
et normalement on devrait gagner cette
partie
il faut
si tron soul
sion
difficile
oui
quatre pièces profiter d'un b4
m'attribue dame c5 ou des choses comme
ça allait moins vite
on continue
quand le gave premier ok j'ai trois ou
qu'il va quitter son fou c'est pas mal
hein je vais faire un truc comme ça
lorsque ça vaut jeu c'est d'être un pion
au centre puis voilà quatre pas mal
qu'après la part de 4,5
des troncs on défend
bon
nous l'avait assez c'est pas mal de sa
part comme ça je vais pas prendre juste
renforcé sans lequel ali par la même
occasion et détruit leurs attaques
bon il va peut-être faire j'ai si c'est
un moment très précis on s'en défend le
choix je suis deux options
faux c'est ron leurs attaques
on va s'occuper des halles ce camp
d'argelès 6 1 lyon
mais quoi d'autre
tu crois pas même jeu
au jeu
très bonne ouverture
/
[Musique]
et ça vaut ce que ça vaut bien le
théorbe de sa part pas mal et c'est doux
vers 1 qui feront par la barre tout ça
la dame peut-être enfin sortir ça nous
manquer mais je suis pas hyper content
de f si ces compagnies vermont dans mon
endroit
cette passif c'est pas ci fais ça
ces droits mettre le truc
bague je vais essayer de remettre le
truc je sais pas trop pourquoi on va
voir on va essayer ok ça va marcher
je vais essayer de remettre truc je
crois que faveur
on les écoute ah ça y est je suis là je
m'endors
you ouais bon bah c'est reparti et cool
voilà j'ai un problème de connexion du
coup je me suis mis sur le téléphone ce
que vous voyez tout ce que tout est
rétabli
non
[Musique]
passons m'entendais bien au quartz l'on
verra dans le chatt désolé donc pour ce
truc n'a du coup je pense qu'on est
tombé dans la partie d'avant champ le
mieux c'était écrit le zéro et bah du
coup nouvelle partie on joue contre
dragon's au mont qui était présent hier
pour la master class joueurs assidus qui
a trouvé les exemples d'exercices des
combinaisons donc attention
et ouais et dont ben désolé pour la
collection je sais pas j'ai perdu la
connexion je fasse sylviane mc box
si un tant soit peu importe c'est passé
faire allez apprendre le centre y en a
marre y en a marre faut jouer vite
au mans
qui est on a ouvert le fou bien la dame
un bon ne fait pas grand chose ne pas
regarder un peu chic et allez on se met
là va peut-être aller bouffer la paire
de chou comment même bien c'est pas de
cracher du foot où tombent l'échiquier
et de rentrer vers lesquelles celles de
l'adversaire
ça peut le faire
légal on n'est pas trop mal dans cette
opposition
on ouvre un peu on nous rend un peu le
jeu
[Musique]
on va se
comme ça on cloue durant ces 6 la dame
qui revient
alors viens on se place de partout
6 dans l île
ça prendrait bond prend allez on va
rentrer avec le cavaliere
on va faire
on va ancrer des menaces quelque 4 et
peut-être faire du cavalier e 2 parce
que c'est grave bien sûr
grave erreur
comme ça on
5 et chaste notre tour eh ben on va
prendre ça on va prendre un f4 prendre
et si on se ramène vers le roy on
constate bouffer des pions
c'est pas mal on est bien on est bien
cette position d'amis six auxquelles
conception des trucs aux menaces des
fois ça déménage cette et victoire ok
allez match sur un jeu constat chiac
sont beaucoup de positions se
ressemblent non parce qu'ils ont pensé à
prendre le centre il ya plus qu on s
était défendu par lequel est donc ça
c'est pas grave qui a et b 3 allez
comprendre le centre une deuxième fois
trois noms qui est un dispositif plus
passif que nos besoins
j'ai des trois ils attaquent sartre ok
on va le défendre
on va le défendre bêtement comme ça
on n'est pas si mal
mif
bon allez on va directement la ville c
plaisante et une déconnexion y parvenir
il faut aller on pousse les pions
allez petit jusqu'au bout ouais ok pour
l'instant on n'a pas compris grand chose
mais c'est pas grave on a mis un pion
plant unit pin vers l'europe
amélie cavalli alors ça on veut pas
loire va t'en
il est parti il ya peut-être faire 24 un
jour et non le faire nous-mêmes battant
et comme cavalier laisser parler avec la
dame
la presse sacrifié
mais faut quand même a réitéré le truc
bon ils se battront pour inviter ses
fils
une position alors qu'il y ait des
quatre là je vais le prendre est ce
qu'on prend en sont succulents chinois
on le laisse
premier regard
peut-être bêta
stasiak je trouve
il joue plutôt vite
je surpris par la rapidité mais bon là
ça lui coûte une dame comme
le vent de bord
non
le puits
cible faut qu'on finisse vite partie de
ses objectifs
c'est logique
m
ah les partitions partie suivante on
avait blanc elle est en plus au centre
les 4 6 avait été relevé une française
on y va
e
qu'est ce que c'est c'est simple ça
qu'il saddam c'est pas mal de trucs
comme ça on va renforcer notre centre
des citrons de chasse vaut pas loire il
s'en va et on va aller à ses pieds on
développe le canal et m6 veut nous
prêter le centre on va dire qu'on le
défende je sais pas crise
triste comme ça et j'ai six jeunes
apprentis coup de cannabis y défend f4
attaque g7
métis qui coûte jetteront des fantômes
non masqué pranger cette menace et déjà
j'ai envie de dire quand
un petit coup de grands
on est à tour en face et bon sang quel
élan g7 il a fait sa vie serait bien de
pouvoir repartir avec un jour
repartons repartons
et dans ce temps les pièces on va le
prendre
enfin qui coule échec si jamais la
pollution s'ouvre centre on est très
heureux très heureux dans l'espoir de
placer laurent à boujan quand même
qu'elle aime qui fout par la tulette
dernier 5 qui arrive à les h4
on s'en prend masse cavaliere
ok c'est un pion là bas
on va bien ce que c'est
ouais on va les bouffer tour
[Musique]
l'inde est le faux 8
apprendre
on a une grande intérieure à l'ap
on programme cavaliers se replacer en
faire de me prendre et cinq au prochain
ff iii en appart et puis on va les mater
ce point à plein échec
hop
sur ces 8 on prend et bye bye
hop alléno le parti et doit le parti
comme dragon's sommes alors ça semble un
peu une potion d'échec normal avec ses
pièces au sens comme ça qu'est ce qu'on
peut geler les petites combines assez de
voir des bonnes âmes
nous la diagonale le foie
jouer
qui ça
pour le centre ont pu repoussé quatre
bougera la dame où est ce qu'on va aller
juste en d6
ok bon jeu
votre position vers l'avant dès 6 et le
défend le simple
on se tourne pas beaucoup plus quand on
frappe et 5 pour chasser le flou on se
sert des quelques trucs confirmé 5 quand
même de faire un jeu de foot chasse et
se fout là qui me regardait vii qui me
plaît pas trop on tient la case de 4
comme ça mais cinq s'accomplit quelques
trucs en même temps c'est pas si mal
bon mais c'est la carte du combo lisions
pas clair du tout je vais faire ça
pas génial génial mais manquent pas
envie de perdre un set j'ai pas envie de
faire plein de trucs comme ça
je vais vraiment cette réflexion peut
qu'aider 600 peu sinon chasser ce cas
valais central qui est très bien placé
qui nous embête
et si on
peut-être qu'on va souffler
bellemare quand on ne veut plus le voir
ce qu'ils avaient centrale
ok on va se développer et défendent b5
au passage j'en à restabiliser tout ça
c'est pas malin avec est-ce qu'il peut
être d'un match 4 qui va arriver ensuite
on lui envoie contre attaque
quel et jetteront fait quatre
imagine droit
voilà c'est pas mal mais mais bon on
gare saint-jean
adepte profonde ghréline en 2001 puis on
le prend
un pion on le prend s'il ya un contre
pourquoi pas aulas temps va-t-on
cavaliers kébé 5 pas mal joué à taxer
cette attaque à 7
c'est pas mal je ne sais pas tu as mal
joué du tout je voulais faire c'est 6
mai c'est ridicule
enfin ces six à prévoir a changé c'était
pas si idiot mais lorsqu ils sont fous
ça ne plaît pas
mais pas tant que ça
[Musique]
c'est bien ce qui ma chance c'est bien
joué c'est chiant à l'est
à la tête
il faut bloquer ces sites
intersport on va vous tuer
mt 3
le truc comme ça
et c'est ici c'est pas bête hein on se
doit peut-être de l'empêcher
chiche
reste en place
position super chaotique je sais pas ce
qu'il se passe
surtout
sa face à vannes on se met alors à cinq
attaques m or est-ce que je sauve si la
qualité
est-ce qu'on ce jeu
e
ou est ce camp sont à l'esprit ce prise
férois là
rien ok ça on y pense r on y pensait
franchement je peux connaître la
position ça semble tout et n'importe
quoi je pensais qu'on était hyper bien
très vite et puis ça a pas mal à tourner
mais ça passe super bien de tourner leur
voix ils ne pompent panique chez nous il
va nous attaquer à cet acquis
c'est la france qu'on me donne
voici un truc comme ça vous se placer
et de l'agression alors
quelles étaient vos pouces
tu vas aller en enfer
la voilure l'eau si cette greffe 4
cette g5
ces trucs qu'est ce que c'est que ce
couche de gras je pense
oprean hockey up sera même
d'autres promenades à 7 m
ce
c'était très chaud
partie et c'est pas le poste à les
nouvelles par qui on va tuer b4 alep
ça fait jour la tour ce que joël adam on
verra ce que ça donne
du coup du groupe b capot on verra ouais
c'est drôle je normal mais bon je pense
c'est important que je assez vite
je sais pas mozart ne joue pas c'est
saïda il a joué et j'ai fait ce type 2 3
on va stopper ce pion dans son élan sur
4 kg 3 pour l'attaqué abcès bonne il
faut pas clair si prix donc c'est pas la
meilleure entame pour lui en voyant ce
qu'on fasse de saddam mon erreur très
bonne grâce extraordinaire c'est g4 tout
seul on y va on a gagné une pièce autant
que ça joue conte s'amène presse du tour
4 que ce soit en coupe du roi
c'est pas des trucs comme ça qu'est ce
qu'on fera aux quatre ont dû manger son
cavalier voilà il est des rockets ok
première bonne nouvelle à l'extrême on
sera avec les pièces ils m'attaquent la
tour alors on rebouche au delà
ils allaient le bout
le défendant qu'être trop content des
changes pourquoi pas
le plein
peut on y va ils attaqueront touche au
tac le sien s'il prend feu je prends le
sien voilà de me faire trop réfute
vraiment ça c'est encore un pion on le
prend taux refi je bouge vraiment roi
c'est pas grave c'est juste un échec
et puis on fera de même avec les pièces
par exemple de melun la salle a pas mal
attaque aux 4 à tinqueux 6
après
chaque
check check in check et nos moyens de
forcer
ouais
je sais pas c'est un peu mou j'espère
pour une partie suivante
serge barbarian à nouveau ok qu'est ce
qu'on va faire on voit quand le centre
les quatre des cinq très classique c4
enfin la zambie dame
formidable normal plus ou moins c'est un
petit envie dame au quesnoy
allez on se développe il nous fait et si
c'est pas mal on apprendre à voir quand
il reprend cavaliers du pion du pion
gold a cette fois eu 13 temps à 8 avec
la dame
au moins est sorti
[Musique]
juste
on peu rauque et à tout moment c'est un
si hockey développe
nos sites nous aussi
le tireur ok ok ok ok j'attendais ça
pour preuve d'assez et on va voir si ça
marche si c'est une bonne idée si c'est
trop présomptueux mais on jours pour
envoyer un peu de beau jeu on veut faire
d'un mach 4 et puis j'ai 5
c'est bon là je savais pas
c
on sait garder l'option pouvoir jeu
grand besoin
c'est ça
peut être
on a des
où on a des atouts à faire valoir dans
cette solution g5 torje un bon jour à la
colonne g allez je vais y aller pour
justin e
bon on m'en pose des petits problèmes
pratiques
parce que ça vaudra
m
menace de prendre à 6
alors nous mais un couloir ok défense
orientale bon moi je continue des coûts
qui me semble logique sans perdre dans
la pendule 100 a perdu à cdg au début
et puis on verra bien où ça nous mène
tout ça
ok prise prise
hp 6e
dommage puisque papier la dame on peut
pas on peut paraître peu mais comment ça
marche si starbucks prend un risque que
l'on prend la suite un tel foin 4 je me
prend je vois pas de suite bons jeunes
buts ristournes
la dame est matée mais j'ai pas mais
j'ai pas vu comment faire ça
contrairement aux attaques habituelles
où la dame et en dit ça nous enlève des
options
je comprends pas
dans le premier set m'a trahi ok ça va
arriver
pas grand chose à comprendre pour le
court c'est une gaffe au caire
peu importe en bon le jeu agressif un
porté ses fruits on me dira et donc nous
la victoire on vraiment pas beau au
classement je sais pas combien de temps
il reste dans l'arena la connexion aux
réseaux 10g patients moment tant d
toujours mais on a livré les blancs et
les f4 ouvrir le fougères f 4g trois
autres comme ça chez 4 du coustou
l'evian on se place à fond sur les
grandes diagonales de cette pièce 14
minutes ont donc développement des
flambées deux des cinq en sortir ce fou
bon
9 5 90 mais bon faire
faire mon espace on va
des trucs comme ça ça c'est pas mal
hop
bon
ses trois clients 7,4 quoi bon alors ça
échange et c'est pas un souci un souci
on défend l'option ou deux on va faire
fou des quatre peut-être au prochain en
cendres a pris la paire de flou
il sera déjà ça de pris
donc
les quatre la date de l'investiture le
cavalier on va faire foule en guinée une
qualité c'est de ça
une telle prise trois filles il faut
plonger 5 7 passes 6 1
du coup il n'a pas pris on le défend et
on va se finir le développement se
placer etc etc
mais c'est pas mal dans une bonne
position
une bonne position
je passe pas mal quoi
en d4 séchant je prends joe dimaggio je
donne à colonna c'est peut être
intéressant pour moi je suis bon je sais
qu il y aurait trop cavalier qui a aidé
s'être on va faire grand roque toutes
les places et
ok
tu veux changer en échange pourquoi pas
et puis après je reviens jouer un coup
comme eux quatre ouvrir la position j'ai
essayé d'ouvrir les lignes pour mes
tours l'école partir de là
allez
allez on ouvre
en outre comme
en attaque la dame on est débordés 8
on a des pions preuve
[Musique]
le trouveront centrales sont bien placés
elle tord adverse temps à huit dates on
fera tour ses trois potes tu prend 1,5
on va voir je veux bien le la finale si
tu veux je veux bien jouer la finale
pour entrer sur les huitièmes et tout
prendre prendre le fou peut-être je
pense va plus prendre avant non c'est
très bien c'est que je savais et
hellemmes ranger sur très difficile pour
adversaire à défendre également a les
parties suivantes ci devient son podium
une nouvelle partie s'est lancée on a
les noirs
votre say say party à 4 4 4 4 4 à 4 5
wen
pièce on va développer
comment sait ce qu'on a à faire ça fait
très bien lui aussi je remercie pierre
fiala bien partie astrologique assez
classique poussé dedans là bas on a fait
des trous dans l'opposition qu'on
n'aurait pas dû faire
des rockets au personnage je sais pas
quel point ce utile de leur vie
choix du tout convaincu par manoeuvre
que je ne faire mais bon on verra on va
dire
après la zéro que c'est toujours ça de
faire
et puis voilà h5 on le fit doré en fonte
à bas ont sévi dans le géant une
connexion en mousse ils sont chaque
couche peut être déconnecté
c'est pas ce qui est plus agréable mais
bon
tour d un hoquet faire ça des quatre
reprises
alors
c'est si fort j'en sais rien mais aline
s'arrête
on va attaquer ce option là bas pour une
bouche
ouais tout
puis refaire des sites des trucs comme
ça c'est ramener le roi comme un rebelle
la prison n'est qu'un tour à tour
revient soit si les manger ça c'est une
bonne nouvelle pour nous du tour66 du x
4 mai à notre se place très très bien
centre a bien tourné
en 30 plutôt pas trop mal tourné
la dame qui défend la dame qui les font
tomber dedans b4 des trucs comme ça ça
peut être cool
il n'y a pas de tour est vite un gel
fois en a quatre qui les font ça c'est
bien
ils normalement on devrait arriver à
mater
demain
à noter et rabih un doublé de l est est
un temps enfin derrière cette partie si
trois quatre matches au centre on verra
peut-être le temps de réfléchir comme
une taille reste est à six minutes
peut-être un peu une fin de partie
on va voir je vais pas trop de réfléchir
sur les pièces et on verra après
hop
il a tenté d'enfermer la tour mais ça va
j'ai qui ressort il s'en va prendre pour
le chasser
va le chasser aussi
ok on bouge la dame on s'active un poil
bon jeu
proc comme ça on est placé et on va y
aller avec 4 f 5 un truc comme ça on va
jouer à la barbare et ses devis
d'attaqué de cavaliers l'agent pas
spécialement si je pousse et on va faire
ça tours petit enfilade
je vais la troupe
[Musique]
quatre attaques
si je vois pas au bon endroit je
pourrais son cavalier sylvain astier
sous thatcher kébé 4 avril après hop
j'encaisse et on garde l'enfilade sur la
taurus 6 j'encaisse prendre le taureau
silice à sortir les pièces jouent et
s'entraînent il ya abandon
ça va on enchaîne les dates encore le
chanteur une partie on verra à les
connexions complètement pls total à
l'aide à la partition bien on est
reparti sur m'en f 4 allée des cinq jeux
seuils de rien donné en a quatre minutes
pour essayer de gagner cette partie
bon j'ai st
sa place stratégique vers la dame
d'avoir des cases pour voir pour me
placer je sors les deux pièces si je
peux g3 pas maître de sa part il défend
il ouvre son fou j'ai 1 à 5
on essaie de créer du jeu de ce côté on
va faire de la pointe rouge on rentre
comme dit vlad
on va bien évidemment j'ai six en
acheter un oeil sur ces deux même si
honda sera une camion et un qui défend
bien mais ça peut être sympa on sait
jamais un jour de monter tout ça
détroit au quai st jacques
1 le 4 ok on va le jouer à prendre le
centre prend le centre bien des points
faire la même chose
mais c'est bien joué de la part d'hommes
et c'est simple on blâme d46 prend bk
toujours prend du plomb art comme ça on
trouve des trucs auxquels il veut faire
tomber cette île peut il prendre
peut-être mesure du cavalier trois
quatre années après je fasse attention
s'il fait froid ou 4 il va défendre ici
j'ai 4 mars à j'avais pas vu et c'est
bien joué de sa part très bien joué de
sa part n'est pas écouté c'est qu'on
continue à envoyer en aura deux pièces
de moins qu'en fait c'est pas terrible
évidemment on qu'on va garder les dames
on peut en
survie position complètement pourri
mais on verra on la trouve
ce jeune finale et marginalise
dire que là on a quoi
deux champions mais vu la tronche des
pions c'est pas terrible
ses pions triplé quoi tripler
catastrophique
ouais c'est bien joué il veut rentrer
c'est pas une chose
m
si comme ça s'il prend il nous remet un
peu les pions à lambres on attaque le
flou un il oublié le clou
bonne nouvelle pour nous petit coup de
chance on avec le cadastre en plus qui a
pas beaucoup d'avenir
donc on s'en tire pas mal sur cet
enchaînement de coups moins d'une minute
j'espère qu'on attend de finir celle là
deschamps
ah ah
je suis revenu pour la fin la fin j'ai
pas même temps il reste on peut être
abattu que ça devait terminer à 45
ça va suffire maintenant finir sa note
mais c'est tout près mauvais plus
possible reste seconde c'est de garder
entré seulement l'art message on ne peut
pas il peut attendre
ouais je sais pas il fait comme il veut
non mais normalement tu ne dois jamais
abandonné arrête même si tu dois juste
attendre te prends moi tu n'as pas
réussi à gagner non l'un des rares états
et des problèmes de connexion j'ai un
petit peu regardé a complètement pas
suer quoi je viens même que j'ai perdu
vraiment assez vite
c'était bien que je suis pris un
découverte et du coup après ce témoin
bien et puis après j'ai une autre
défaite sur des connexions et du coup
j'ai su afin que la connexion d'après
l'onu à la fin je me dépêcher à fond
j'ai envie et ouvert lé roi attend enfin
jouer aurait fait quoi
voilà un beau début c'est d'expliquer un
peu ce que je faisais tout ça après je
croyais qu il fallait juste marseille
nice qui a gagné la compétition au aux
barbarians emma que tu as battu je crois
je crois que j'ai regardé la partie
barbarian ouais je n'ai gagné que le
fouet
il pense que c'était important de gagner
il fait 10 derrière pourra penser gagner
des parties mais ça marchait sur le
téléphone à peu près rien je crois que
parfois ça ça laguait un peu mais au
[Musique]
moins ça allait attendre et j'ai pas
j'ai pas le château youtube ce que moi
je regardais sur mon téléphone
donc je sais pas ce que disent les gens
dans le chat mais oui c'était ça souffre
et moi quand j'avais laissé un peu dur
en bruit de fond et ça souffrir un peu
quoi certains moments un petit peu
weight a souffert avec la connexion est
vraiment souffert c'est je sais pas
pourquoi en photo mais c'est en ça
marche et c'est à dire il ya certains
joueurs pendant la vitrine cup pourquoi
où je sentais que c'était un peu moyen
mais le truc c'est que quand je suis à
côté en fait
j'accélère je parle beaucoup et le temps
que ça revienne quoi ouais absolue en
fait c'est juste ma box qui pète un
plomb peut être que
me connecter dessus ni rien par chance
j'ai fait la 3g mais bon c'était pas ouf
philippon plus philippe cheviré qui a
préféré le crédit à rousseau 960 voix
lors qu'ils aient ou c'est quoi c'est
quand tu joues tout seul vous séparer
ses beats à quatre salles s commence
peut-être la prochaine fois du coup tu
fais bah pourquoi pas l'occasion
c'est marrant je pense avoir ancré suis
à fond dedans je veux rater avec les
touches à c'est pas possible ça
n'appartient pas à cette position
ce cas ralliée de merde qui peut poser
mais pose souci même mirage qui est des
gens qui l'ont et 1960 va écouter enfin
moi c'est pas mal de faire des petites
versions différentes de temps en temps
tu es sur laquelle n'a quand même pas
rien du coup cette semaine on aura tout
tester
quand on a fait trois échecs en a fait
roi de la colline roi de la montagne on
a fait notre sens tu à 103 échec pour la
montagne c'est soit tu gagnes aux échecs
soit tu gagnes sur la montagne
ouais bah alors ça ressemble vraiment
aux échecs normaux ça du coup c'est
encore différent quoi et oui il y avait
un bug en fait sur le programme ça m'a
écrit m'a dit oui je suis au courant et
peut-être on arrêtera de stream sur
youtube parce qu'apparemment depuis hier
il ya des problèmes sur youtube nous sur
twitter ce crime raffut sur youtube on
voit que twitchell youtube serait
peut-être qu'on sait encore s'il occupe
un peu plus loin c'est plus possible de
faire un moulin et puis ça a commencé à
bloguer tuyères et puis donc ces
rouleaux à d'abord dit contre la triche
est way attend sur west ils sont pas
faciles ne sont pas faciles à gagner cet
aréna maintenant très dur très dur
les mecs sont là ils veulent te l'a
collé quoi bon écoute sur ce j'ai envie
dire on se retrouve
moi je suis resté soir des petites
parties pédagogie contre 1200 web avec
toi demain à partir de 16 heures du coup
pour les la compétition des jeunes là et
ouais mais petit les jeunes ouais tout à
fait tout de l'afp en croit sa fin que
devant un parterre de stars
adoma tout le monde alors merci